[Musique]
g
xavier mathieu bonjour bonjour bureau
nous avoir invités et ben merci d'être
venus sur tours parce que vous êtes sur
le plateau tv soixante dix huit pour un
vip qui vous est entièrement consacrée
vous êtes ici car vous êtes le
commissaire d'une magnifique exposition
qui a lieu en ce moment qui a lieu à
versailles et qui a lieu plus
précisément au musée lambinet voici la
fiche donc cette exposition elle est
consacrée un peintre qui était tombé un
petit peu dans l'oubli qui est beaucoup
de succès sous une époque on peut
comment on peut le définir il s'appelle
antonio de la grande arts a déjà dire
son nom c'est pas mal et dites moi a dit
moi ce qu'elle a été le ses débuts de
carrière son début de carrière fans ont
alors donné un grand ara il a un nom à
consonance espagnole
wima l'a déjà c'était c'était en fait d
origine mexicaine par son père qui
arrive en europe en 1856 et puis qui
rencontre son épouse et ils auront trois
enfants et antonin gandhara et l'aîné un
taux nul à gondar à rentrer très jeune à
l'école des beaux-arts notre héritage de
16 ans il habite paris il est né à paris
d'accord et donc très vite il connaît sa
voix son ca sa vocation il demande a
donc à faire des études d'art
apparemment il rentre après des études
au lycée condorcet à l'âge de 16 ans il
rejoint les cours de jérôme être cabanel
à l'école nationale des beaux-arts des
armes poisson
sati son auto portrait réalisé en 1888
avril à quel âge à peu près il a 27 ans
c'est un 27 ans il commence sa carrière
très jeune donc oui mais heureusement
d'ailleurs parce que finalement il
mourra aussi à ces jeunes il mourra à 56
ans ce qui est assez jeune et sexy jeune
voilà donc il appartient à ce qu'on
appelle la belle époque et vous même
alors donc commissaire de cette
exposition musée lambinet pourquoi vous
mais moi je suis descendant de de
l'artiste via sa deuxième épouse n'a
qu'à et quand quand mon père me fait me
fais cadeau des oeuvres qui ont toujours
été dans mon entourage et qui était sur
les surveiller sur les murs de notre
maison de famille ouais je m'intéresse à
l'artiste c'était il ya vingt ans et 20
ans pascal auparavant on en parlait pas
plus que ça dans votre famille ou naïve
et il faisait partie de notre
environnement la veuve de l'artiste
vivais chez mes parents
elle est décédée chez mes parents oui
comment s'appelait tél elle s'appelait
charlotte saint-andré de son nom de
jeune fille et à portrait d'elle
d'ailleurs dans l'exclusif plusieurs
portraits d'elle dans l'exposition elle
a été sa muse sa deuxième le après sa
première épouse d'accord et alors
comment est-ce qu'il a donc il a démarré
sa carrière donc très jeunes ont souvent
l'écho du peintre jérôme aux beaux-arts
comment at il gagné sa vie déjà alors
qu'il a lancé comme ça s'est passé alors
c'est la rencontre avec robert de
montesquiou un versailles et que tout le
monde connaît à versailles un revers de
montesquiou donc est un homme de lettres
poèmes de leyte impôts est interdite en
disant qu'ils rencontrent les massaï qui
habite versailles cette époque là et
qu'ils rencontrent en 1885 la gandara
chez lui alors on voit pas dont robert
de montesquiou son portrait là il est à
droite a effectué sur vos sous visuel
robert de montesquiou détecte dans la
gandara là la qualité d'un peintre qui
l'intéressent et il en fera un pas trop
mondain allant même jusqu'à lui demander
d'utiliser sa particule dans ces
signatures parce qu'à l'origine la
grande aire racing endarra tout
simplement ou simplement un monogramme g
ou lg et après la rencontre avec
montesquiou is in de la gandara voix
antonio de la gandara n'est écartée
puisque c'est plus chic et puis
montesquiou lui a fait rencontrer tous
les mondains toute l'aristocratie qui
tourne autour de montesquiou la comtesse
greffulhe hélène greffe lui bien sûr la
comtesse de montebello et puis tous ces
portraits là sont réalisées grâce à
montesquiou et oui il introduit qui
l'aide d'agents quelques chars en
totalité
il est d'avoir des commandes donc les
portraitistes est ce qu'on peut dire
portraitiste monde 1,6 et moraliste
mandat c'est ce que l'histoire retiendra
de lui
bien que il est aussi réalisée
des pastels fort sympathique très
délicat et puis des paysages parce qu'il
s'est beaucoup intéressé à versailles
oui 2 au parc de versailles et au statut
du parc de versailles d'accord mais ce
qui lui fait gagner sa vie concrètement
ce sont ces portraits tout au fait
qu'ils sont quand même assez particulier
à savoir en général de très grand format
tu es très grand c'est impressionnant
tout de même c'est ils ont presque deux
mètres de haut des exactement des
portraits grandeur nature année en
format qui sont souvent précédés de
pastel qui lui permet à 10000 travail
d'étudier les postures et de convenir
avec le modèle qui est souvent
capricieux surtout dans la gente
féminine
évidemment parce que c'est le modèle qui
paye c'était bonnet le client on peut
dire ça comme ça
client aura donc la cliente si on peut
l'expression aime à voir ce que de ce
que sera un peu l'aperçu de sa posture
de sa coiffure de ceux de ses toilettes
moi j'avais une question donc des
avancées qu'il est très attaché au
costume du modèle il fait faire
expressément une robe on parle d des
portraits de femmes pour l'instant
d'ailleurs il ya une salle qui est
consacré aux familles une salle qui
consacré aux hommes et aux autres salles
qui consacré aux op la stèle et aux
ménages
donc ça c'est dit sur la structure la
scénographie de l'expo donc les
portraits de femmes
il fait faire expressément une robe par
un de ses amis un des grands couturiers
parisiens très souvent très souvent il
se rendait avec ses modèles qui étaient
déjà clients des grandes maisons de
couture et il se rendait chez doux
sécher paquin chez les ch et paul poiret
et il choisit ses ensembles
effectivement la toilette dans laquelle
le personnage sera immortalisée voilà la
leçon et visuel que vous avez ici vous
avez des effectivement de très belles
robes de wenzhou paquin way qui sont
présentés sur des tables
ses tableaux sont pas à l'exposition
d'ailleurs un cd tableau qu'on aurait pu
faire valoir ce qu'ils sont ce là par
exemple alors ses tableaux là il y en a
un qui est alors celui qui est à gauche
il est au musée du petit palais mais il
n'a pas pu nous prêter parce qu'il est
présenté en ce moment a pas aux états
unis dans une exposition qui s'appelle
paris 1900 ne du milieu et en allemagne
et celui de droite et aux etats unis
c'est madame gautreau la célèbre madame
x de monsieur sarr gens qui avaient fait
à l'époque un scandale pour la nudité de
son épaule à celui-là qui a choqué les
années
c'était le porter de sergent qui avait
une bretelle gros tels qui pendaient et
qui avait choqué le tourisme américain à
l'époque d'accord donc pour en revenir
aux toilettes dont qui est magnifique il
ya magnifique portrait en or bleu cette
robe bleue a été créé pour l'exposition
tout à fait c'est bien c'est une robe
qui a été réalisé par injurié parisien
qui est qui est professeur au musée
galliera notamment et qui nous a réalisé
la robe qui est présenté en animation à
côté du tableau qui ici présentés et qui
est sur le modèle gravier qui est une
versaillaise et qui la fille naturelle
de l'artiste d'accord est-ce qu'il a eu
des enfants il s'est marié deux fois oui
il a eu des enfants à chalais eu deux
filles
il a eu deux filles de son premier
mariage et puis une fille avec une
liaison qui a qui lui a coûté son
premier mariage parce que d'accord la
première épouse n'a pas vraiment s'il
n'a pas vraiment apprécié les gens son
petit esprit bon
dites moi tous ces modèles magnifique
qu'il porterait tease
les femmes sont vraiment tout des lianes
ya une finesse extrême les mains sont
fines le pied et petits cambrai le
visage et voilà alors ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'il refusait les lébous
lot qui voulaient de fer portrait tease
et se dit pour traîtrise et oui tout à
fait mais il refusait les gens qui
n'étaient pas dans ces normes ou où les
zombies l'isère où toutes les femmes
étaient minces n'est ni les embellies
sais pas il les peignait tels que tels
qu'ils les voyaient ils étaient même
très très sélectif ah ben voilà
mais sélectif pas sur le reste et
physique pas sur l'aspect physique était
sélectif sur le fait qu'il voulait sa
liberté pour traduire pour traduire le
personnage qui pose est d'accord et non
pas traduire ce que le personnage aurait
voulu qu'il soit qu'il soit présenté
comme tel je comprends
c'est la raison pour laquelle comme il
avait un carnet de commande de deux ans
devant lui à portrait par la grandeur à
n'était pas automatique il lui arrivait
de refuser de prendre des modèles donc
il ne peignait que finalement des femmes
qu'ils avaient envie de peindre aussi
qui qui avait envie de peindre et avec
lesquels les changes les changes qui
précédait la commande de tableau et a
été satisfaisant à ses yeux n'est fait
un brushing
on peut penser qu'il avait un bon
feeling très bien alors donc pour se
délasser de ses portraits de commande
qui ont fait qu'ils ont créé vivre ils
allaient dans les jardins de versailles
il allait voir son ami robert de
montesquiou donc on a des pastels qui
représente le parc est ce qu'on les voit
dans l'exposition oui bien sûr dans
l'exposition voit notamment la la statue
d'apollon du belvédère du bassin du
bassin d'apollon du parc de versailles
il a réalisé plusieurs trianon également
vous avez tout à fait raison
les pouces et moselle ces modèles ses
modèles étaient était assez capricieux
l'ennuyer un petit peu sur la fin de sa
vie notamment
il se plaignait que il allait toujours
avoir à réaliser des portraits féminins
et voulait plus cantonnées dans ce but
les lasers douala il voulait élargir son
le spectre sa peau nette et c'est à
cette époque là qu'il a réalisé c'est
don quichotte et diane et actéon c est
une guerre à ses études de conte de fées
et puis comme vous le disiez très
justement il aimait aller se reposer
dans les jardins que ce soit le jardin
du luxembourg qui était à côté de son
atelier parisien où le parc de
versailles qu'il fréquentait très
souvent et qu'il considérait comme son
paradis terrestre sont parés des
terrasses carrément c'est un peuple
qu'on a comparé à vélasquez je me trompe
tout à fait c'était jean lorrain qui
aimait à a surnommé
la gandara veulent à 16,1 pas ce que
veulent velasquez tout comme tout comme
ribot était un petit peu les les
artistes qui étaient au panthéon de
l'artiste qui était au panthéon de la
gandara c'est à dire ils les admirais il
les avait copié quand il était quand il
était jeune et ils ont inspiré beaucoup
et on a l'impression qu'il a kill et
qu'il a une véritable jouissance à
peindre ces matières sublime finalement
presque favori mais c'est un vrai
plaisir pour lui je pense de deux pintes
ces étoffes ses lumières cette offre la
manière dont il traitait le la moire de
la soie le la cassure d'une étoffe ses
atalante harrie noy lui était très
particulier d'accord donc lâché
entraînement très le livre que vous avez
écrit sur l'avis d'antonio de la viande
haras il y a aussi le catalogue de
l'exposition oui voilà on encourage tout
le monde à y aller je sais pas si les
petites filles d'aujourd'hui aiment
encore dessiné des robes de princesse
mais là elles auront un moult aux
modèles tous plus ravissants les uns que
les autres
et vous alors monsieur xavier mathieu
vous avez des projets pour l'avenir
vous êtes complètement consacré à ce à
votre votre aïeul et qu'est ce que vous
avez envie de faire maintenant bien ce
qui serait ce qui serait assez logique
dans le cheminement
après le livre sorti en 2011 après cette
magnifique exposition organisée par le
musée lambinet son équipe qui est
formidable
ça serait de pouvoir trouver un musée ou
plusieurs musées qui seraient intéressés
par par une exposition plus thématiques
et plus caractéristique de l'oeuvre de
la gandara à dire qui serait une
exposition sur le peintre de l'élégance
féminine et on se
on pourrait pour cette occasion
rassembler une cinquantaine d'oeuvres
majeures du style de celles qui sont
présentées à lambiner dans la grande
salle avec les portraits féminins
puisque nous avons des oeuvres qui sont
aux etats unis des oeuvres qui sont en
italie des oeuvres qui sont en autriche
des oeuvres qui sont en belgique et qui
pourrait être rapatrié sur une grande
exposition et et faire faire en sorte de
montrer que le peintre costumier de la
mode qu'ils étaient puisqu'il était
président de cette association à
l'époque
ah oui puissent être honorés la scène en
tant que peintre féminin oui je comprend
et sait les tableaux qui sont donc en
europe et aux états unis sont dans des
maisons particulières où ils sont dans
des musées alors aux états unis mais le
portrait de la comtesse de montebello
par exemple dans une galerie le portrait
de madame gautreau et dans sa muse est
d'accord ok c'est variable travail
énorme que le portrait de madame donne
aux young et en italique et quelques
magnifiques également nos sommeils rose
il est dans la descendance de madame
d'annunzio d'accord ou écouter xavier
mathieu un grand merci bravo pour ce
beau travail et merci nous avons me l'a
fait découvrir ce peintre antonio da
gandhara et donc j'encourage tout le
monde à aller au musée lambinet jusqu'au
mois de février
merci à voilà merci beaucoup
[Musique]